相変わらず、すごいなあ
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
今、ヒカキンさんの家に
居るんですけども　皆さん最近
親分の家で何が起こっているか知っていますか
そう
G！
あ、全然違う
本人からも聞いたんですけども
めちゃめちゃゴキブリが出るらしくて
そりゃもうたまった量じゃないらしいです
ヒカキン：家に帰って来たら　壁に
クワガタよりでかいゴキブリがいます
(荒い息遣い)
は：で、親分はゴキブリが大嫌いなんですよ
動画見て分かる通り
なので、このタイミングを逆手に取って
ふっ..
あの…このなんかね
別に　なんか　すごいしょーもないんですよ
やる事はしょーもないんですけど
僕なんかゴキブリがたくさんありすぎて要らないんで
逆に親分の家ならゴキブリが出る可能性のある中で
こちらのゴキブリのおもちゃを
親分の部屋にこっそり置いて
親分のゴキブリに対する警戒心が
かなり高くなってる訳ですよ
出るかもしれない前提で動いているので
逆にこれだとドッキリだと気づかれないので
やり易いのかなと僕は思っております
というわけで　ゴキブリ仕掛けていきましょう
ヒ：休もう党を結成しました
ヒ：休まねえみたいな
シルク：ずっと続けるみたいな
ヒ：休まないかもしれないけど、
休もう党を結成しました
は：休むかもね、みたいな？
シルク：ちょけまくる、ちょけまくるみたいな
ヒ：それだね
ヒ：なにかある？　撮りたいの？
ヒ：ｗｗｗ
ヒ：だから今日は休めって言っても
どうせ休まないから
ヒ：もう強制的にこの…
３人：休も♪　休も♪　休も♪　休も♪
休も♪　休も♪　休も♪　休も♪　休も♪　休も♪
ヒ：最初はブンブンジャンケンポン〜
バーイ
は：ひぃ...
は：親分、このサングラスいいっすね
ヒ：ほんと？　これはね、あの子と一緒なの
ヒ：リクオ君！　　シ：へえええ！
ヒ：ああぁ、ああぁ、
ヒ：撮ってもねえのかよ！　そして
ヒ：撮ってる～www　　シ：（拍手）
ヒ：撮ってもねえのかよって言っちゃったよ！
は：撮ってました！
ヒ：カットだよカット
は：完璧でした、今
ヒ：カット！
ヒ：最近いるからさ、ゴキブリがさ
は：そう！　そう
ヒ：えぇ。。。
ヒ：３本動画上げってからね、ゴキブリの
ヒ：なんかまだ設置してんな
は：親分、iVIS持ってるんすか
ヒ：持ってる。それもう売ってないじゃん！
は：えー、僕も買いましたよ
ヒ：ああ、超高いやつ？
は：高いやつ、そこのそこの
ヒ：うわ～、それか
は：これでもいいですよね
ヒ：いいね
ヒ：なんか怪しいなあ
は：いやいやそんな
ヒ：え？
ヒ：ｗｗｗ
ヒ：もう引っかかんないよ！
は：さすがに